what is up everyone welcome back to the
cinema center at marble at Tiff 2023 I'm
very excited to be here talking to the
team behind one of my favorite movies of
the festival Close to You huge huge huge
congratulations on your movie like we
were talking about before I just have a
very good feeling that this is one that
years and years later I will always look
back on the 2023 festival and think of
thank you that's so nice thank you so
much Dominic Elliott I'll throw this
very challenging question to you I feel
like ever nobody ever wants to give the
synopsis of the movie but because many
of our viewers will first be learning
about close to you here can you give a
brief description of what the movie is
about it's it's about going home it's
about it's about love I mean I want to
keep it quite General as well because
you get specific but actually it is
about going home it's about family the
difficulties of family and it's about
love you ready for that question
could have fooled me
um for the two of you because I love
talking about when two collaborators
find the right creative partner in this
industry can you tell me about your
first meeting together and maybe what
you saw on the other that signaled to
you like you're not just good at your
own job but you are gonna help me bring
the best out of my work as well well I
mean for we first met we had a meeting
on Zoom
and I'd seen uh Dominic's work the first
thing I saw was the film he did with
Samantha Morton that
completely blew me away I couldn't stop
thinking about it I couldn't stop
feeling it like it was like living in me
and Samantha Morton's one of my greatest
Inspirations and uh the filmmaking was
just so intimate and raw and
uh so it was so thrilling to then have a
zoom meeting and connect so deeply and
that's really where it started we really
just connected
um our love you know for certain film
and art and
the process I think we approach it
similarly and and how we like to make
things and create and
I just felt so grateful that Dominic um
uh was interested in having me be a part
of uh his work really I just felt
immediately that we met
you know I just felt all of his humanity
and
and and and and passion
and I I just just it was one of those
meetings where you think this has to
happen
like I have no choice this has to happen
because this feels like such an
important moment
um and also the sense in which I knew
that Elliot was going to just throw
himself into it I just knew that you
know because it's quite scary working in
this way but I just knew he was going to
go for it and so that's really important
you know if you're if you're not sort of
sure about it or if you think Hmm you
know but not with Elliot he was like
yeah many many questions about the way
you filmed this movie Hillary I'll throw
my first one to you when you hear about
the way they are going to shoot this
film what are some of your biggest
burning questions for Dominic to make
sure you feel confident jumping into it
um I when I found out that the the
process was going to be improvised I was
mostly just excited because it's such a
fun
um challenge there's so much Freedom as
an actor and
um I had a couple of gyms with Dominic
and we also really hit it off I felt
like I could trust him so much which is
so important with this process I'm a mad
in person that trashed and connection
just grew and I just felt a little
nervous of course before but once we got
started it was um I fell into it and it
was so such a such a joy to get to to be
a part of this and I'm really grateful
thank you Ellie I'll build on that with
you now there was something in our press
notes or another interview you did you
said that at the beginning of this
production process you had never done
anything like this before and you were
nervous about it I think the specific
quote was like how does Dominic do this
so now having gone through this process
can you answer that question how did
does he do it and Dominic
this is like
really leads with his heart he leads
with feeling he leads with Instinct he
leads with just wanting to find honesty
and create something that feels real
how he manages to connect and cast all
these unbelievable actors that make up
the cast of this film and
and how he works with you know
you know crew and and the collaboration
and
um the trust I think we feel for him and
the trust he feels for the people he
works with and it just
it creates this experience on set that
really is unlike anything uh uh I've
ever done
and so much of that is just
guess who Dominic is as a person and how
he's
able to work with um cast and and crew
who are obviously a
integral part of creating something like
this like we would do
you know we could do a 50-minute take
and you're thinking of like Catherine
holding the camera and sound and the
boom operator and it's just
I'm explaining it that well but I guess
I'm just trying to say I think it's
uh I think the answer is just who
Dominic is as a person and and
his intentions and I feel like in this
industry we Overlook that particular
quality in a filmmaker too often and it
makes all the difference Dominic I did
want to ask you about Catherine and
selecting her as your cinematographer
here what was it about her that signaled
to you she wouldn't just get the visual
style right but she could actually do
something like what was it a 53 minute
take was the highest the highest you got
yeah I mean it's the same process in a
way when when meeting
um Catherine
you know it's it's a sense in which you
feel someone is going to
um it just really understands what
you're trying to do
feels it not just understands it but
actually feels this thing because so
much of it is about what one feels when
making the scenes they are
um they unfold in a way that's
where they start to just go deeper and
deeper and they get they get more
interesting and they get more you know
um
you you start to see truths that that
actually you could never imagine even
you know
um but it requires uh sort of love and
patience and instincts again and I just
knew that Catherine had all of those but
we actually just worked really well uh
you know that thing where you're in sync
with someone and it's almost like what I
liked she liked what she liked I liked
you know it's all that it just kept and
and I've had experiences I mean way back
where I didn't maybe I think you you
develop an ability to have an instinct
for people more and more as you as you
grow and I remember way back having such
an a non-sync synced kind of camera
person and it was a nightmare you know
you can't have that you've got it It's
gotta be that they're totally in tune
with everything and Catherine was all
the way you know it didn't surprise me
when I looked up the credits and saw her
name as a cinematographer because I had
just seen Swan Song and that that is a
cinematography feat and how they fell
into sync with the dancers on that film
and they they told me that they learned
the dances and lost something like 20
pounds given the the physical
requirements of filming something like
that so it just seems like she very much
gets the material she works with on any
film I do want to talk about the whole
ensemble here but first Elliot and
Hillary for both of you can you tell me
something about the other as a scene
partner that you appreciated and maybe
helped you reach something in your own
character that you wouldn't have been
able to without them well I mean
Hillary's just
sorry Hillary but I'm gonna it's just
astounding and we met years and years
and years ago and did a movie together
called the East but we didn't really
have much to do in it together but we
just deeply connected there was a scene
that I don't even think was ended up in
the movie
where we were just looking in each
other's eyes it was like an exercise in
the group and we just started crying
together like we're just like
yeah and then maybe that's what sealed
the deal like something just connected
and we've stayed friends and wanted to
work together
and have been trying to figure something
out to do and then this happened which
was amazing Hillary
is the most
I mean again talk about someone who
leads with their heart
who is one of the kindest
people I know and who
there'd be moments where
like I'd be feeling like oh no I'm
feeling tired I am I going to be able to
tap into this scene
and then I'd be there with Hillary and
everything just came out
so
she's just such an incredible actor
her instincts are so amazing and
there's just days without her that I
would not I just don't know if I'd be be
able to get there and that's a testament
to her and
uh and her amazing her incredible Talent
thank you that's very sweet
um
but I feel better about you and I
remember that first vaccine that we did
together I think it was the first day of
filming at least 10 minutes I was like
this I feel like it was the first thing
we shot it was like it was amazing um
yeah since then
um we just had this very natural
deep easy connection that ways of course
a part of you know working together now
and
um I always knew as soon when when
filming this as soon as we would you
know the camera with all that we were
both just there and you were so
with me and open and it allowed me to go
so far and to trust you and trust the
moment and track myself and yeah an
amazing actor and just so so real and
transparent and beautiful so thank you
yeah I need these tough interviews so
badly right now just like fills my film
linking heart in a challenging time in
this industry I'm gonna end with two
kind of big-ish questions uh Elliot I'll
throw the first one to you because one
of my absolute favorite things to see is
when an actor with a big platform uses
it to get the movies that they're most
passionate about made that maybe
wouldn't have been made otherwise so
what does it mean to you to have that
power and also what are some goals you
have for yourself in the future in terms
of how to use it wow gosh well I mean I
feel incredibly privileged obviously to
um be in a in a space where I could
influence anything like that and to me
uh you know utilizing my privilege and
my platform to
tell stories I want to tell or um you
know with my you know production company
page Boy Productions to uh you know
really get to be doing that and
a more significant way now
um
uh you know it it means the world to me
and as
you know I'm here getting to do what I
do now because of so many people before
me and
I hope to in whatever way I can uplift
and uh
yeah that's
yeah that's a major goal you're doing
exactly that and I have very high hopes
you're gonna keep doing it for many many
years to come
this is I feel like this shouldn't be
the hardest question that I ask but I do
feel like many have a hard time
answering this so in this industry we
tell each other good job all the time
but I feel like no one says it to
themselves nearly enough so for each of
you what's something you accomplish on
this movie that you know you'll be able
to look back on and say to yourself damn
I am really proud of what I did there oh
that's hard
um
I'll say to be honest going into it I
was
pretty scared shitless I like as it was
leading up I was like what the hell like
improv this whole thing's improvised was
I kidding myself
um Dominic's gonna be so disappointed
like I was really
uh and so I think
for me just
being able to
step in with no dialogue do have this
brand new experience where
I think we do
find them
create some pretty you know beautiful
scenes which is because of also the
incredible actors I work with but just I
think
it does feel like an accomplishment to
have made something in in this way it's
not scary it's probably not worth it
yeah well I I think actually it was what
was interesting for me it was the first
film I've made out of the UK it's the
first film I've made in a completely new
territory and
and I came to it with just a really open
mind and heart and like just it just
that's what I'm most proud of is
actually starting completely from
scratch with something
and and just building it and building it
and finding the the great people that
are in it to work with
you know and all of it was a completely
unknown Journey which for me just really
really worked and I remember
um there were certain things that we did
on certain days and
Elliot would text me and said that was
something special and that meant so much
to me because you know I knew he was
feeling it and I was feeling it and that
that's made the whole thing worthwhile
oh
it was just um
it was such a unique
as an actor and as a human and just
um
being so immersed in the story and being
start feeling so collaborative with the
two of you and the crew throughout the
whole process I definitely
um you know came out of it and felt like
wow what did we just do that is really
really something and I feel like what if
we can
you know touch people and open those
hearts and Minds a little bit and um I
feel incredibly proud to be a part of it
and and I love as a deaf actor that
um that I'm just in it and I'm a part of
it and it's not you know a big issue not
that there's anything wrong with those
stories but it's exciting because it
feels like progress where many many
different
people can be involved with storytelling
um as as human so I do feel very bad to
be a part of it with both of you
incredible honest too beautiful answers
all around I lie one more really quick
question just because I'm curious the 53
minute take what scene was it it a lot
of it's not in the I mean as you can
imagine we do it was the build up to
um Sam comes home and comes into the
there's the whole birthday celebration
and that was that was long
the beach was long the beach our walk on
the beach and yeah the the the dinner
the pre-dinner
um discussion was long
but yeah no there were a lot of long
days that 53 minute one where we played
pool and I like happened to be sinking
all of these shots I was like why is
that not in the movie I was like
magically incredible at pool I was like
are these like acting gods or something
what's going on as someone who has
planned to the tea for a 15-minute
interview the fact that you're able to
do that on this production just blows my
mind very very special movie you made
here huge congratulations to everybody
watching close to you do not miss it
keep an eye out for it and also stay
tuned we'll have more interviews from
Tiff 2023 for you very soon